it's cheesy it's gooey it's creamy it's
super satisfying and you never want to
stop eating it
hey guys my name is Elvin and today I'm
gonna show you how to make my chili
cheese party dip I really want to show
you guys how to make this dish because
I'm cooking for people and I love really
making them happy and this dish is a
guaranteed party pleaser the first thing
in this recipe is to make the dip
filling itself for that you're gonna
take chili and you're gonna take cream
cheese put it together microwave it and
stir it until they're completely
combined the second step is to prepare
your bread vessel one way to do that is
to use a bowl flip it over on top of the
bread bowl and kind of use that as a
guide to trace around the edges so that
when you kind of cut through and scoop
it out you end up with one giant piece I
usually make this dish for parties
especially when there's a lot of kids
this always hits a home run every time I
think cooking is at its best when you
have someone to share it with whether
it's someone to feed or someone to cook
with so the inspiration from this dish
actually comes from my childhood I used
to grow up going to company parties that
my mom would have with her co-workers
one of the hosts his name was John
amazing house amazing dinner parties the
food was incredible
there could be all this food but I ate
this one dip he had on the table and I
would be eating that a whole night and I
just kind of camped by that and just ate
that continuously I would always
remember going back to his parties and
being excited because I was oh we're
going to John's house he has this
amazing dip so the next step is you take
the bread bowl which has now been
hollowed out you pour the chili dip
inside and then you sprinkle cheese on
top of it and brush butter around the
sides of the bread bowl to give it extra
flavor because I really like butter
that's pretty much it you take it out I
always like to sprinkle something green
at the end I think it really adds a
festive touch makes it really
presentable at a party and because this
is a party dip there needs to be party
food so that means carrot celery steaks
chips other bread baguettes whatever you
want to dip into this dip I dip you dip
we all could dip
this looks amazing it smells amazing I'm
really excited to try it and share with
my friends because I think they're gonna
love it yummy
fun fact when the dip is all finished
and you have a bread bowl left you can
actually cut it up and rebake it and you
have magically 20 more breadsticks with
dip on it and that's just free food that
came out of nowhere so I like that if
you're really a party pleaser and want
to be the most amazing host ever you can
also make a dessert I have a video
that's called eight desserts in one
sheet pan
it is literally a guaranteed to please
everybody at the party because it's
designed that everybody gets every piece
of dessert that they want so whether
it's cookies brownies apple pies M&M
bars Blondie's pumpkin pie you will make
it and everybody's gonna get something
that they love and everyone will love
you for this sheet pan dessert I've
separated into eight sections so you
have two popular desserts like brownies
cookies pies cheesecakes s'mores you can
really take any section and make a
dessert that everybody else likes so
feel free to customize it the tricky
thing is you have to try to make sure
that the walls stay still so whether
it's pie crust graham crackers you
really want to keep those sections
distinct so everybody gets a piece that
they like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]